ATTENTION FOR INJURIES, POLICE
ARE STILL SEARCHING FOR THE
SHOOTER.
WE HAVE MORE INFORMATION, WE
WILL BRING IT TO YOU.
GUNFIRE BRINGING OUT ACROSS THE
BORDER ONCE AGAIN, TEXAS TO
PERMIT OF PUBLIC SAFETY SAYS
SUSPECTED CARTEL MEMBERS WERE
TAUNTING TEXAS NATIONAL GUARD
SOLDIERS BY FIRING SHOTS OVER
THE BORDER.
RACHEL: LAWRENCE JONES GOT A
FIRSTHAND LOOK AT THE CRISIS
AND THE CONSTANT THREAT OUR
BORDER AGENTS FACE.
PETE: LAWRENCE JONES IS HERE TO
DISCUSS.
>> IT IS ROUGH OUT THERE WHAT
THESE NATIONAL GUARD ARE
DEALING WITH AS WELL AS
TROOPERS ON THE GROUND.
WHAT YOU SAW IN THAT VIDEO, WE
CAN’T CONFIRM THEY ARE PART OF
THE CARTEL BUT WE KNOW THE
CARTEL WORKS WITH THESE PEOPLE.
THEY WERE TAUNTING A WEEK AGO
WHERE THEY WERE TAUNTING THE
NATIONAL GUARDSMEN, YESTERDAY
AROUND NOON THEY FIRED OFF TWO
SHOTS AT THE NATIONAL GUARD.
THEY HAD THE TEXAS RANGERS
INVESTIGATE.
WHEN I TALK TO MY SOURCES THEY
PUT IT SIMPLY, DURING THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION THEY WERE GOING
AFTER THE CARTEL, MADE SOME
HEADWAY, THE DRUGS WERE STILL
POURING IN BUT THEY WERE IN A
DEFENSIVE POSTURE.
SINCE BIDEN HAS BEEN IN OFFICE
THEY HAVE GOTTEN BOLD, FIRING
SHOTS, YOU MAY HAVE SEEN BILL,
THE BEST BORDER REPORTER ON THE
GROUND FIRING SOME SHOTS ACROSS
THE BOARD.
YOU WOULD THINK AMERICA, THE
UNITED STATES WOULD GO INTO
OFFENSE WHEN THAT HAPPENED,
THEY ARE NOT SO TEXAS IS LEFT
TO INVESTIGATE.
AS THEY TELL YOU, INVESTIGATION
STOPS AT THE BORDER.
YOU CAN’T HAVE TEXAS RANGERS GO
ACROSS THE BORDER.
WE HAVE OUR GUYS GETTING SHOT
AT.
PRESIDENT BIDEN AND KAMALA ARE
NOWHERE TO BE FOUND.
JILLIAN: THEY OWN THIS BORDER.
>> IT’S NOT JUST PEOPLE COMING
THROUGH BUT DRUGS, HUMAN
TRAFFICKING, IT IS ALL ONE POT,
YOU CAN’T JUST SAY THAT THE
HUMANS IN AND BUT NOT THE DRUGS
IN, IT DOESN’T WORK THAT WAY.
I TALKED TO THE GENERAL,
OPERATION LONE STAR, HE SAYS
THEY WILL SEND FOR MEN BUT WHO
WILL PAY FOR THIS.
DOES TEXAS HAVE TO CONTINUE TO
PAY FOR ALL OF THIS, WE ARE
RUNNING OUT OF MONEY TO DO
THIS, TEXAS HAS BEEN GREAT WHEN
IT COMES TO FISCAL
RESPONSIBILITY BUT WE HAVE A
SEMANTICS GAME IN THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION, THEY DON’T WANT
TEXAS TO CONDUCT THESE ARRESTS
AT THE BORDER, THEY SAY THIS IS
A FEDERAL ISSUE.
IT IS A FEDERAL ISSUE SO GET
DOWN HERE AND DO YOUR JOB AND
YOU HAVE BORDER PATROL, WE
CAN’T TO FOOT PURSUITS OR
ANYTHING AND THEY DEPEND ON GPS
TO DO THEM AND TURN THEM OVER
SO A LOT OF BACK AND FORTH,
EARLIER THIS WEEK WE HAD
FOOTAGE ON A RIDE ALONG WITH
THE TEXAS TO PERMIT OF PUBLIC
SAFETY SPECIAL OPERATIONS UNIT
IT MAY HAVE SEEN 60 ILLEGALS
CAPTURED ON PRIVATE PROPERTY SO
THE GUY CALLS AND SAYS COME OUT
HERE ON THE SCENE AND ARREST
THIS GUY, BORDER PATROL RUNS TO
GET THESE GUYS AND THEY SAID
ESSENTIALLY OFF THE RECORD WE
ARE GETTING A LOT OF FLAK FROM
THE ADMINISTRATION BECAUSE
TEXAS IS MAKING US LOOK BAD.
THEY COULD SIMPLY DO THEIR JOB
AND BORDER PATROL’S CREDIT THEY
WANT TO DO THEIR JOB, THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION IS NOT ALLOWING
THEM.
>> INSTEAD YOU HAVE TEXAS
AUTHORITIES CITED ALMOST A NEW
POLL TO ARREST PEOPLE FOR
TRESPASSING ON PRIVATE
PROPERTY.
>> WHICH IS A MISDEMEANOR THE
ONCE THEY HAVE THE HEARINGS
THEY CAN’T PAY THEIR BAIL SO
THEY STAY BEHIND BARS.
AFTER THEY’VE DONE THEIR TIME
IN TEXAS THEY TURN THEM OVER TO
BORDER PATROL.
WILL: WHAT ABOUT THE TEXAS GPS
FORCES, WHAT IS THEIR TRAINING?
>> Reporter: REGULAR TROOPERS
DOING TRAFFIC TICKETS, TEXAS
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC SAFETY
SPECIAL OPERATIONS UNIT,
ESSENTIALLY THE SWAT TEAM
CONDUCTING SEARCHES WHEN IT
COMES TO THE TRAINS BECAUSE
THEY HIDE ON THE TRAINS ON
PRIVATE PROPERTY BUT THEY
DIDN’T SIGN UP FOR THIS.
THEY ARE BEING PLACED IN A
SITUATION, THEY ARE WILLING TO
DO IT BUT WHEN I TALK TO FOLKS
ON THE GROUND, THIS IS WHY THEY
ARE FRUSTRATED, THE PEOPLE
THERE CATCHING COMING ACROSS
ARE BEING VERY CLEAR THAT THE
PRESIDENT SAID THEY COULD COME
AND YOU SEE A GROWN MAN
YESTERDAY BREAKDOWN WHEN I
ASKED HIM HOW LONG HAS IT BEEN
AND YOU HAD WATER AND FOOD.
THE GUYS IN THE HOSPITAL.
I’M NOT SAYING OR ENCOURAGING
PEOPLE TO BREAK THE LAW BUT
WHEN YOU HAVE THE
COMMANDER-IN-CHIEF SAYING IT IS
OKAY TO COME ACROSS THE BORDER
AND THEY GET ARRESTED I DON’T
THINK THAT’S A HUMANE POSITION.
WEARS A AC WITH THE TEARS AT
THE BORDER.
IT WOULD BE NICE TO COME TO
TEXAS AND SEE THE CONDITIONS
THESE FOLKS ARE GOING THROUGH.
RACHEL: OR THOSE LITTLE GIRLS,
4 AND 6 YEARS OLD AT ALL BY
THEMSELVES WITH A NOTED ADDRESS
THAT THEIR OWN LIVES SOMEWHERE
IN THE UNITED STATES, BORDER
PATROL FOUND THEM THANK GOD AND
NOT SOME PEDOPHILE OR EVIL
CARTEL PUTTING INTO SEX
TRAFFICKING.
THIS IS SOME TERRIBLE STUFF.
SHAME ON AOC FOR NOT BEING IN
TEXAS WHEN SHE SHOWED UP WHEN
ELECTRICITY WENT OUT DURING THE
TRUMP ADMINISTRATION OUTSIDE
DETENTION CENTERS CRYING, WHERE
IS SHE NOW?
>> LASTING I WILL SAY ON THIS,
PEOPLE WONDER HOW TEXAS HAS THE
MANPOWER TO DO THIS, TEXAS JUST
HAD ITS LARGEST CLASS FOR THE
TEXAS STATE TROOPERS.
ALL OVER THE COUNTRY YOU SEE
THE DEMONIZATION OF POLICE.
YOU ALWAYS HAVE THE PURPOSE,
EVERYBODY KNOWS THERE’S BAD
ACTORS BUT IF YOU DON’T SAY
THAT THEY SLAM YOU.
PART OF THE REASON TEXAS IS
ABLE TO DO THAT IS THEY FEEL
SUPPORTED.
THEY KNOW GUYS OUT THERE ARE
DOING THEIR JOB AND ARE TRYING
TO KEEP THEM SAFE.
THEY DID NOT SIGN UP TO PROTECT
THE UNITED STATES BORDER BUT
THE LAST DEFENSE OF THE
COUNTRY, LESS DEFENSIVE TEXAS
IS THE TEXAS STATE TROOPERS AND
THEY DIDN’T SIGN UP.
IT IS A FEDERAL ISSUE.